okay hey everyone it's Michael fos here
from orderflows and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Tuesday
May 16 and you it was a very interesting
day we made new highs in the S&S uh then
we later sold off so let's take a look
at what happened um the tools I use in
this presentation are the orderflows
Delta scalper and most importantly the
orderflows footprint chart the
orderflows trader um as I like to call
it you know the overflows what separates
the orderflows trader from you know a
lot of the other footprint charts out
there is you know I have additional
orderful tools already programmed in
there so it takes a little bit of the
analysis off your shoulders you you're
still going to do analysis of the market
but it's the way that I've used
orderflow in my trading career that you
know I was able to program some of the
tools that I use I used to do it in my
head or on a calculator and you know
when I was talking to a programmer I
said hey you know is it possible to do
this he says yeah I could put that in
there so that's why I've developed this
orderflows Trader footprint chart which
just takes the your normal footprint
chart a step further um you know you
don't have to use my footprint chart to
watch these videos and get something of
it again you know you can figure a lot
of this stuff out on your own um you
know again I do these
videos mostly for my users that always
send me questions and you know ask me
you know what happened during the day
but again it's also for other people
that want to learn orderflow trading
again I apologize um my voice
sounds kind of congested I still have
this cold I'm fighting hopefully I'll
get over it by the weekend I have this
presentation on Thursday with investor
inspiration um at least my cough is
mostly gone I still have this very
scratchy cough that comes out but before
I jump in a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results
so let's jump in you know again I said I
have a
um a
webinar presentation this uh Thursday
and one of the things I'm talk about in
the presentation is imbalances and the
importance of imbalances in your trading
now you know I I was meeting to send out
an email then you know my wife gave me
this medicine and just sort of knocked
me out and but you know I do want to
show you guys something that is is very
very revealing in orderflow now if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
okay
here you have this swing low here
you rally up a little bit come back down
then rally go up come back down and then
rally now is there anything in this in
these bars that are tell I'm going to
tell you that you know we're going to
pull back to this level here you know
110 51 11052 or um you know
110 58 59 60 no you don't get any
information on on a chart like this but
if you're looking at a orderflow chart
you know it's it's very revealing it
shall reveal all
um what time was that that was around 4:
this morning scroll back
here okay so this is that low here this
is that swing low right that I was
talking about just talked about here
it's this bar
418 this uh hammer then you see the
little you know the green green red
green and then up here green red red
green okay now here's your Hammer here's
the green red green notice how we pull
back to this level here then we
rally get back up here green red red
green we pull back to this level here
and then we continue our rally
well is there a way you can determine
that hey you know we might pull back to
these levels yeah there is it's called
the imbalance and you can see here you
have aggressive buying here you have
aggressive buying here and it's stacked
it's what's called a stacked buying
imbalance if it was Reds it'd be called
stack Sol imbalance and what makes it
stacked is they're just right on top of
each other okay so why is that important
is because you know we hit this low
right we hit this low we start to Rally
up aggressive buying comes in you know
there's there's never more buying than
selling but what you have rather is you
could have more aggressive buying than
selling or more aggressive selling than
buying and it shows up in the order flow
chart so you have a stack buying
imbalance here which means you at this
at this area very aggressive buyers came
in here to move the market higher okay
the buying dried up a little bit came
back down more aggressive buying came
back in here and we you know the buying
that was here earlier is reappearing and
we make them move higher so you I'm not
saying it's going to predict that oh
we're going to pull down here you know
when when you're looking at this low I'm
not saying you know over the next couple
bars we're going to come up come back
down to level and rally no rather okay I
see a stack buying in Balance here okay
you know we rally hey we're starting to
come back down let's see if this area is
going to hold you know there's a very
high chance it can hold and it did H it
did held it did
hold and we started to Rally up okay
same thing here we get here you know hey
we can go higher but if we go higher and
start to come off Watch What Happens
when we come back into this
area okay it's kind of hard to see there
so we're
rallying okay starting to come back down
a little bit coming back in this area
we'll see if this area is going to hold
that's what you want to see you know our
buyer is going to come back in here low
and behold here we do get through it by
you know two ticks but look which volume
you got down here you got 161 you got 71
94 there's decent buying there to
support this market and we start riling
up aggressive buying comes in boom boom
boom we go higher you know that that's
the beauty of orderflow now you know
another thing I want to talk about is is
staying on stacked imbalances is this
fiveyear right um this is a great
example today about taking trades in
context of the market okay so we're
rallying you know it's a big it was a
big rally in the bonds and 5 years today
and you know rallying going into these
highs what do you see when you're going
into highs you see buying imbalances
that's a good sign that we're going to
still go higher it means there's there's
strength in the market you see buying
and balance buying and balance buying
and balance that's good that's good to
see get up here at the high you have a
ratio and a Divergence again to me
that's already go the problem is it's
coming right on the back of this bar
here these this three in a row I talked
about this analysis in the trading room
today but I going to share it with you
again it's a three in a row this is a
setup I like with the red bar and then
the green bar back here I like this it
just so happens it's you get this very
bearish bar right here in the middle of
it but you know what there's no one
putting a gun to your head saying you
got to take this trade or you got to
take this trade what you do is you wait
you know let the market confirm things
for you so you know at this
point okay you're thinking well I got
this very bullish sign now it's a
bullish sign but it's going into highs
and we just been making new highs I'm
not a big necessarily a big fan of
buying into new highs I'd rather be
looking for reasons to sell but that's
just me okay say you're not me and
you're thinking oh I got a hard on
because I got these new highs here going
in you know we got a three in a row you
got you know ratio ratio ratio you know
price rejection type ratios single
prints single prints you know a small
print here but then the problem is you
get to this bar you got a Divergence
you've got a bearish ratio you know it's
also a small print ratio so it's telling
you it's conflicting things I'd rather
not get this if I think if we're going
higher I'd rather not get a Divergence
and a ratio up here but nevertheless so
now you're conflicted what do I do I'm
sitting on the back you know this is a
setup I like I like you know three
ratios in a row then the Red Bar problem
is this bar is a very bearish bar I
don't like it with the ratio and the
Divergence so okay let's wait let's wait
for this Market to tell me something so
wait for the next bar that's all you got
to do again you know there's nobody
putting a gun to your head saying you
got to make a decision choose the right
one or I'm going to blow your brains out
no you know the you you trade you don't
trade you know what you do is you wait
for confirmation okay the next bar it's
green it's up I'm thinking I got to go
with up you know because if I think it's
going to fall over I need to see some
some bearish signs okay so you got three
in a row and this is setting up you know
I said if I could just put my finger
over this 488 and this uh Divergence
signal there then you know it'd be all
systems go but you know at this point
I'm likeing yeah okay we maybe we can go
higher you know I'd be I'd bite
I'd be looking to bite now the only
thing is I'd rather be getting in the
ideal entry on a three in a row is
between these two point of controls um
of the third bar and the second bar you
don't really come back there so you
don't really get the entry that you're
looking for then the next
bar big red
bar and you got to stack sellum balance
at this point you know I've got three in
a row but now I've got you know a
bearish bar Divergence with the ratio
then all a I got a stack sell imbalance
at the
high I really got to shift my idea
because you know one I didn't get the
ideal entry that I like and I'm looking
at another bearish thing here so you
know one I didn't get the good entry and
I've got another bearish sign up here I
love stacked sell imbalances near highs
of the days and it's coming right on the
back of you know another nice bearish
ratio so at this point again you know do
I sell or do I not sell I see point of
controls right at the same level you
know this is this comes down to trade
management or not even trade management
at this point it's trade uh what do you
want to call it trade uh trade
psychology do I take this trade do I not
take the trade I got a lot of things
conflicting with me every other bar is
conflicting with the previous
analysis um so at this point what I'm
looking at is the two- pointer controls
here you know they're at the same level
what I want to see is is this next point
of control going to be below this if it
is then I think it's definitely light
out and you got to be short and it is
it's one tick below it's right around
the same level actually but it's one
tick below you had a single print in
here one at 1 1812 which to me is a gap
you know I I treat you know these thin
areas people call them thin areas I call
them single prints cuz I like to see
single prints if it was 20 would that be
a single print no but it'd be a thin
area but just optically one of those
things you know a single print I think
stands out more so now I think it's
lights out this Market's you know
heading south and what does it do lower
lower lower the next bar down next bar
you know lower then sort of just bounces
up goes sideways lower lower and you
know but really you know if you could
have got it and this was a tough one to
trade I'll be honest with you um you
know might have been looking to get long
in here but as soon as you see the stack
sell in a balance you got to get out you
got to be getting out here at take your
loss of you know two or three ticks four
ticks maybe um and get out so you know
but this you know it again honestly you
know it was a tough one it was a tough
one
but if you stick with it don't get
married to this three in a row and
that's one of the problems people do is
I get married to trades and you know
think well I'm already in this position
I we give it a chance to work out and
then it doesn't work out um then it just
Falls over now the other thing I want to
talk about I don't I saved it but then I
didn't save it was this S&P chart the 10
range I saved it a little bit late but
if you're looking at the volume profile
here forget this part up here if you're
looking at the volume profile at this
time I remember talking about this again
in the room you have this what you know
this sort of ledge here when you get
past
2475 very thin volume I said we get when
we're trading down here at this time at
uh
01 o and 3/4 I said if we get past dou o
and a half it can just sell off pretty
quick and I did save the screenshot here
just after we got through it but um you
know if if you look at the actual 10
range chart
um just get it in
here you know
this ultimately this is how it ended up
looking um yeah know we sold off from 24
and a half down into the lows of the day
down here at 23 93 and
3/4 then I remember again I was
discussing in the room with
everyone and you did have this l low
here and I said you know are we going
higher or not you know this was the big
decision I was faced
and I want to see the signs and what's
the first sign I'm going to see is
obviously the the ratio the price
rejector but this bar here this candle
very strong negative Delta and it ended
up at minus 900 okay I I like that you
know it was pushing lower pushing lower
selling was coming in selling stopped
you know buying took over so it's a
swing fromus 4,000 Delta 4,900 00 to
only minus 900 so you know it's like you
just ate back an additional 4,000
Delta nevertheless if you don't buy that
type of analysis watch the point of
controls in the bars if we're going to
be if this is going to be your low look
for this point of control to hold and it
it did it came right down here that's
your support here it came down within a
tick that's your support here it came
within a tick that's your support but
you know these two bars here especially
with the ratios were you know kind of
indicative that we can possibly be
rallying a little bit I didn't expect
such a nice rally back off all the way
back up to o or or 01 and a half think
it was 01
and but you know in the night session
we're trading much lower right
now and you know was there anything else
I got to keep this short u
my my throat is a bit painful uh I just
want to talk about the soybeans real
quick you know sort of mix it up a
little bit so yeah you have your double
top here you sell off um you know no
ratio there but you know you come down
here and this is something that I've
been talking about a bit you know watch
the Delta you know people think W you
know Mike talks about Delta you should
become a Delta tin foil hat guy but you
know look at this move from your high
down you know lower point of controls
boom you get down here your first green
bar look at the Delta minus 465
ended up at minus 41 very similar to the
snps and next bar you get the Delta
scalper given a
buy but you know if you're watching it
you can just see how the Delta you know
it's just kind of waning it's going you
know it's getting weaker on the way down
and it turns positive Delta scalper
gives you buy boom all the way up into
new highs of the
day you I don't like to say trading is
easy but sometimes you know the market
tells you something that that's very
obvious and you know people lose sight
of that you know they want to analyze
every tick you don't need to analyze
every tick if you're looking at a dome
you're you're literally going to have a
heart attack staring at every tick
trying to analyze it well what's coming
in what's you know what's traded what's
oh there's another 500 being offered uh
two ticks above oh you know this that
you orderflow is is something you can
sit back you could you know enjoy a nice
cup of coffee or cup of tea as you're
watch it it develop and you just look
for those moments you know it's like
football it's like soccer rather you in
the US it's it's soccer football America
not football Americano Just you know
soccer you know it's a super boring game
I'll be honest with you but I watch it
why because I'm looking for those
moments of Brilliance you know where the
guy you know gets the pass you know
catches it on his chest controls it with
his foot dribbles past Defenders and
then puts the ball on the back of the
net and you know that's what orderflow
is like you know you're looking for
those moments where something stands out
in the market and you look to capitalize
it like you see here in the soybeans and
you saw in the five
years so again you know hopefully you
know this video was was useful as far as
um imbalances go and again you know I'm
going to keep this short because my my
throat is killing me and you know again
you know I've got this presentation on
Thursday I do hope you guys can attend I
will be spend in quite a bit I don't
have a lot of time I got 45 minutes but
I will be talking a bit about imbalances
I'm going to show you guys another way
to use imbalances everyone thinks of
looking at imbalances as you know I want
say continuation but you know a market
that's going higher you're going to see
imbalances but I'm going to show you how
you another way to look at imbalances as
support okay or resistance and it's
going to be quite revealing so again
I'll put the the link to the webinar in
the description
you could go to my website go to my
YouTube channel there's other links in
there but you know if you want to learn
more about orderflow go to my website
orderflows
docomo uh or soorry you could go to uh
my website and find out more about you
know a lot of the the interesting things
that are going on with uh with
orderflow so thanks everyone and I hope
to see you on Thursday